Here's the dovetailing trick which
let's you run a countable set of
computations all at once.
We'll illustrate the technique for the
case where we're simulating a machine M
on all binary strings
with this table here.
Every row in the table corresponds
to a computation, or a sequence of
configurations that the machine
goes through for the given input.
Simulating all these computations means
hitting every entry in the table.
Note that we can't just simulate
M on the enpty string first.
Or we might just keep going forever
filling out the first row, and
never getting to the second.
This is the same problem that we
encountered when trying to show that
a countable union of countable
sets is countable, or
that the set of rational
numbers in countable.
And the solution is the same too.
We go diagonal by diagonal, first
simulating the first computation for
one step, then the second
computation for one step.
And the first computation for two steps.
Then the third computation for one step.
The second computation for two steps.
And the first computation for
three steps.
And we just keep going,
diagonal by diagonal.
Eventually every configuration
in the table is reached.
Thus, if we're trying to recognize the
language of Turing machine descriptions,
where the Turing machine
accepts something.
Then a Turing machine in
this language must accept
a string after some fixed
finite number of steps.
Say that configuration
appears here in the table.
Well then we'll eventually reach it
with the dovetailing strategy and
we can accept.